hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
saurian calm and in this video i'm going
to be going over in fun pneumonic
specifically to help you remember those
insulin peak times and what type of
insulins are in each category like the
rapid the short the intermediate and
long so this video is part of a series
of the diabetic series I'm going over
for in CLECs review so be sure to check
out those videos a link should be
popping up with the playlist that you
can access those videos and also after
this video be sure to take the free quiz
so you can test your knowledge on how
well you know this material ok so the
biggest thing that really gets students
I never got me during nursing school is
remembering which insulins fall into
certain categories and what are their
onset peak and duration times well in
nursing we have to get a little creative
on how we remember things because
there's so much to remember so first
let's go over what insulins fall into
each category good techniques to help
you do this is write out the word
insulin and we're going to use each
letter to correlate whether it's rapid
short intermediate or long now how can
you remember that and rapid is the
fastest and long types the longest so I
like to remember
Ready Set inject love because with
diabetics were injecting them so um
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to use this word and we're going
to write out rapid so rapid is the first
one it's the fastest so rapid our next
is short
ready set so short and we use the s over
here and we're just going to separate
these because this is going to do with
Rapids and this is going to deal with
shorts and then the next is
intermediates which are you're like mph
is humulin and the UN in fluent is in
the middle intermediate means middle so
we're going to write in humulin in
because it's MBH then we're just going
to separate that from that and then the
L those are our long-acting
we're just going to rock long to help us
remember so now we have it separated
into categories now let's fill in which
drugs fall into each category okay so
human logs
the logs like Humalog and Novolog those
are our rapid so we have Hume log and
then we have no vlog so we have our
Rapids next and our Shore acting all
short acting insulins are your regular
insolence so if it's an insulin name and
it ends and are like no Valen are or
humulin are that is regular short acting
insulin so we're just going to write
he's the orange short and right regular
I'll remember that
and then humulin in those are our
intermediate acting remember you was the
middle of the word insulin so we know
that's intermediate and those are drugs
that end in in and like NPH and then our
L for the long acting that is levy
mirror and Lantis so web Amir and Lantis
now we have it by category that can help
us understand it how I really recommend
you learn this is watch this part of the
video over and over get out your sheet
of paper and just fill it in yourself
and it eventually clicks and whenever
you're going to go take your exam just
hurry up and write it down so you can
refer back to it whenever you're
answering those exam questions now the
next big thing you have to remember
about insulins are those onset peak and
duration times the peak is the really
big thing you want to pay attention to
and because this is when the patient is
most at risk for hypoglycemia when that
drug is peaking so to help us remember
this we have I've developed these
mnemonics I try to make the mnemonics go
along with the nursing profession
because if you can remember something
that you can and relate with you will
help you remember better so I've
separated them too rapid short
intermediate and
acting each mnemonic the sentence the
phrase is going to tell you whether it's
Rapids short intermediate or long it's
going to tell you the onset the peak and
the duration by the numbers in the
pneumonic and they're all in order so
let me show you what they say
okay rapid acting rapid acting the onset
is 15 minutes the peak is 1 hour and the
duration is 3 hours so remember this
phrase 15 minutes feels like an hour
during 3 rapid responses this tells us
we're dealing with rapid acting because
rapid responses 15 is our onset an hour
is our peak and 3 is our duration ok
let's look at the next one
sure acting onset is 30 minutes peak is
2 hours duration is 8 hours remember the
phrase short staff nurses went from 30
patients to 8 patients short remind you
it is short acting 30 is the onset 2 is
a peak and 8 is a duration okay next one
intermedia acting onset of these drugs
are 2 hours
the peak is 8 hours the duration is 8
hours remember the phrase nurses play
hero 2 8 16 year-olds okay the end and
nurses the pee and play and age and hero
that tells you that's NPH remember mph
is your intermediate acting insulins 2
represents the onset 8 represents the
peak and 16 represents the duration and
the last one long acting you're on sets
of these this is actually the most
easiest one to remember because there's
no peak and there's only 2 new numbers
you have to remember onset is 2 hours
peak there is no peak with long-acting
insulins and the duration is 24 hours so
remember the phrase the two long nursing
shifts never peaked but lasted 24 hours
so we know we're dealing with long
acting because we're long 2 is the onset
there was no there's no page
was long-acting and 24 represents the
duration so I hope that helps you
remember the different types of insulin
your patreon sets in your duration be
sure to check out this up the other
diabetic seri videos that I have and
don't forget to take that free quiz and
thank you so much for watching and
please consider subscribing to this
YouTube channel